[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANUJ GOYAL: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting webinars daily.
You're watching
Cloud 101, where we
discuss the fundamental concept
of Google Cloud Platform
and learn from the best
practices in different markets.
My name is Anuj.
And today, we will be
talking about how to manage
Chrome Browser from the Cloud.
You can ask questions
any time on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
Before we dive in, let's
talk about the importance
of the browser.
The browser is about
more than productivity.
With the rise of Cloud-based
enterprise applications,
more and more enterprise data
is flowing through the browser.
That data needs to be secured.
And mitigating security risks is
a top priority for enterprises.
For some enterprises, the
need to manage the browser
comes from a compliance
or regulatory perspective.
Enterprises operating in
heavily-regulated markets
will often lock down specific
features of the browser
to reduce risk, or
enforce business needs.
With the bulk of enterprise user
activity shifting to the web,
the browser needs to play an
active role in the enterprise's
security posture.
Today, we'll discuss
how the browser
plays a large part in user
productivity and enterprise
security.
Here are the topics
that we'll be going over
in our webinar today.
First, I'll talk about some of
the benefits of managing Chrome
and why enterprises
are increasingly
making use of Chrome's
management features.
Then, I'll cover Chrome
management options
that we offer today.
Third, I'll introduce Chrome
Browser Cloud Management,
a brand new option for
managing Chrome from the Cloud
that we're making
available to everyone.
And finally, I'll walk you
through a demo of its core
features.
The way we work is changing.
And the evolving role of
the web in enterprises
has a large part
to play in this.
More and more work
today is done on the web
thanks to the richness
of the enterprise
Software as a Service
ecosystem that's grown
and the web platform
that powers it.
In that context, the
browser is quickly
becoming the centerpiece
for the delivery of business
critical applications.
As you can see from
the statistics here,
both IT administrators
and IT workers
are seeing this shift firsthand.
73% of enterprises
agree that the browser
has become more important
to their IT strategy.
65% of workers report
relying more heavily
on their browser today than
they did two years ago.
So in many cases, it's
about making your enterprise
users more productive.
That's also where
management comes in.
Administrators can
configure the browser
to work optimally for
their environments
from having the right
printing defaults configured
automatically to installing the
right extension for their video
conferencing provider.
And that's why we need
to manage the browser.
It's a great way to achieve
your enterprise's productivity,
compliance, and security goals.
Chrome supports a very rich
set of browser policies.
And as an
administrator, you have
access to hundreds
of browser policies
that allow you to configure
almost any aspect of Chrome.
Here are some examples of
where enterprises often
rely on browser policies to
achieve their business goals.
First is managing extensions.
Enterprise admins want to
be able to enable or disable
extensions based on
their enterprise needs,
control what types
of permissions
an extension can request,
and send customized messages
to employees when they
tried to install extensions
that aren't allowed.
Deploying preset
options can make
the browser feel more
integrated into your enterprise.
The right certificates,
proxy settings, and services
can be configured by the
admin so that the browser just
works by default.
Controlling updates
ensures that the browser
is up-to-date and protected
from vulnerabilities.
And last but not least,
as I mentioned before,
Chrome supports a very rich
set of browser policies.
And as an
administrator, you have
access to hundreds
of browser policies
that allow you to control
every aspect of Chrome.
So today, enterprises have two
options for managing Chrome.
First is to use your
platform's existing management
tools to set Chrome policies.
If you manage Windows services,
you can set policies using
Microsoft's
software-- excuse me--
Microsoft's group policy
objects to configure software
on Windows.
We offer admx templates to
make it easy to set policies
on Windows.
And we offer options that
are appropriate for Mac OS
and Linux.
Second, for enterprises
that already have G Suite
or have adopted Google
identity, those customers
can use Google Admin console
to set user policies.
When their users
sign into Chrome,
Chrome fetches and applies
those user policies.
But each of these
approaches have
their own set of drawbacks.
With existing management
tools, a simple policy change
that needs to be applied
across Windows, Mac, and Linux
might take three
different administrators,
three different tools, and three
different deployment cycles.
It's a lot of extra work
just to set a single policy.
And also, when admins
rely on user profiles,
that means that
employees have to sign in
to Chrome to apply the policies.
And not every enterprise
wants to use profiles
where users have to sign in.
To solve these challenges, we
created Chrome Browser Cloud
Management, which
is an easier way
to manage Chrome
deployments of any size
from a central Cloud location
across Windows, Mac, and Linux.
It's also easy to implement.
Your end users do not
need Google accounts
to receive policies.
And there is no need
for your end users
to sign into the browser.
You'll also gain deeper
insights into your deployment.
With this new feature, admins
can immediately see information
about the policies that are
set, the current versions
of the browser, and even which
extensions are installed.
The best part is that
all this information
is available from a
simple web console.
So if you're an existing
G Suite customer,
you can get started right away
by signing into the Google
Admin console at
admin.google.com
and navigating to the
Device management pages
and selecting Manage browsers.
You'll find instructions on
how to enroll browsers and get
started on that page.
If your enterprise has purchased
Chrome Browser Enterprise
support or have Chrome
Enterprise licenses,
your admin console also has
this new service provision.
Similarly, if you've provisioned
Google Cloud Identity,
your admin console also already
has this service provision.
If your enterprise
doesn't have G Suite,
or they don't use
other Google services,
you can still test this
feature at no charge
at the link listed here.
We'll also display
this information again
at the end of the webinar.
So enrolling browsers into
Chrome Browser Cloud Management
is super easy.
Once your administrator
account is created,
you can sign into the
Google Admin console,
navigate to the browser
management pages,
and create your
organizational unit structure.
Once your structure
is created, you
can retrieve your
enrollment token
for the organizational
unit that you would
like to enroll browsers into.
With that token, you will
use your existing tools
to set one last platform
policy on the devices running
the browsers that
you want to enroll.
Once that token is
set, the browser
will enroll itself into
the Google Admin console,
receive browser
policies from the Cloud,
and you can choose to enable
the optional Cloud reporting
functionality, which will
send some information
about the state of
your browser deployment
to the Admin console.
Now, we'll give you
a firsthand look
at the administrator experience
for a Chrome Browser Cloud
Management.
In this first video, you'll see
how to retrieve an enrollment
token from the console.
Here, the administrator
is already
logged into the
Google Admin console.
And you'll see them
perform a few steps.
First, they'll navigate
to the browser list page
by locating the Manage browser
cards in the Device management
section.
Once they've landed on
the browser list page,
it will list the currently
enrolled browsers.
And finally, by clicking
on the yellow button,
they'll retrieve
an enrollment token
for one of the
organizational units that
has already been configured.
Next, we'll take a closer look
at the sorting and filtering
options that are available
on the browser list page.
From the Device
list page, we can
use Search and sorting
to quickly get insight
into the state of the fleet.
We'll sort by browser
version to find
Chrome browsers that haven't
been updated in a while.
Those machines might
be good candidates
for applying the
force restart policy
that helps ensure
that Chrome stays
up-to-date at a reasonable pace.
In this view, we'll go over
some of the browser details
that you can obtain
if you choose
to turn on the optional
Cloud reporting feature.
You'll be able to view the
extensions that are installed,
which policies are set
on the specific browser,
and what plugins are installed.
Here, you can see that
the admin has clicked
into a specific machine.
And they have a
lot of information
available to them
about this machine.
You can see the extensions
that are installed,
which policies are set
on this specific browser,
and which plugins are installed.
Very good information.
In our last demo, we'll take a
look at the browser extension
list page.
This page is
particularly handy if you
want to get an overview
of the extensions
that your enterprise
end users have
installed across your fleet.
First, we'll look at the
Browser extensions list.
We can see how many times an
extension has been installed.
And we can even force
install extensions.
You can see we're force
installing the Doc
extensions now.
Next, you'll see how
to set a new browser
policy in an organizational
unit with Chrome Browser Cloud
Management.
We'll navigate to the
browser policy page.
Then, we'll give you a
quick overview of the types
of policies that you can set.
And then, you can
use the search box
to find Cloud
reporting user setting
and turn it on for the
whole organization.
This will install an
optional extension
that you can use to get more
insight into your browser
deployment.
Adding this extension is
what gets a lot of the data
and information that you've
been seeing in the demo
so far, including the
Extensions list page.
So Chrome Browser
Cloud management
enables you to see a ton of
data about your organization.
And this service
has its own terms
that are compatible with
Google Cloud's other services.
We also offer a
data export service
that allows you to
take your data with you
at any time, deleting
the browser results
and the associated information
being deleted from the Admin
console storage system.
Your data is yours to keep.
So what's in store for Chrome
Browser Cloud Management?
Well, we already
support a very rich set
of policies in
the Admin console.
And we want to make even
more of the 300-plus policies
that we support today
configurable from the Cloud.
In particular, we want to
bring Cloud policy controls
for enterprise-specific
features, such as legacy
browser support and for managing
updates, into Admin console.
Additionally, we've
heard from customers
that controls around
enterprise security,
such as Password
Alert, are important.
So we want to bring these
features into the Admin console
as well.
That concludes our quick
tour of Chrome Browser Cloud
Management.
It gives you a quick
way to manage Chrome
across Windows, Mac, and Linux.
It gives you great insights
into your browser deployment.
And it gives you the ability
to delegate browser management
separately from other
management work.
You can get started
today by visiting
g.co/chromecloudmanagement.
We also have a
wealth of resources
to support you as you
deploy and manage Chrome.
There are two in particular
that I'd like to point out.
Enterprise release
notes-- we offer
a very rich set of
enterprise-specific release
notes at every Chrome release.
If you're an
enterprise admin that
wants to stay abreast
of changes in Chrome,
this is an excellent
way to do just that.
Additionally, our website at
chrome.com/enterprise contains
a ton of information about
how you can manage Chrome
in your organization.
And with that, thank you
for attending our webinar.
If you'd like to get started
with Chrome Browser Cloud
Management, please visit
g.co/chromecloudmanagement.
Thank you for tuning in.
Please visit Cloud OnAir for
more content from Google Cloud
experts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]